[Music]
hi I'm Dustin Kirkland product manager
at Google and I'm here with my colleague
JD Velasquez product manager at Google
for stackdriver
he's going to tell us about the exciting
announcement from earlier today so we
just announced the beta release of
stackdriver kubernetes monitor which
provides rich compact and comprehensive
observer ability of a kubernetes
environment simplifying operations for
both developers and operators that's
interesting so stackdriver is a gke
specific monitoring solution oh now this
is actually one of the great things
about this announcement and solution and
it is pre integrated with google
kubernetes engine but it can be
configured with any kubernetes
performance no matter where they are in
in kubernetes a follow that's
interesting on other cloud providers or
own front now how does this tie back to
my prometheus for instance a great
question so the stack public amenities
monitoring solution integrates and works
very well with open source we have an
integration with Prometheus so if you
have a your application configured and
instrumented with Prometheus you can
bring that into stackdriver without
modification so now you have a single
place where you can have a unified
solution with metrics logs events and
metadata about your kubernetes
environment including application
metrics as well as custom metrics into a
single place to give you that richer and
how difficult is it to turn on if I want
to start monitoring I want stock driver
monitoring my existing cluster what does
that experience look like it's very easy
it's a if you get that observability
right out from the box as soon as you
have a your kubernetes deployment you're
just gonna enable monitoring stop Robert
dunder yeah cool and what about the
chattiness how cloudy is stackdriver
there's a lot of data to be logged how
does that work there's a lot of data but
that's the the important aspect of it so
this unified solution will get logs out
of your kubernetes environments metrics
as well and events but we give them in
the right context so for instance if
you're a developer you want to get that
data to understand the normal behavior
of your applications right and to do
analysis and diagnosis when things for
if you're an operator you can use that
same data in a different view and at the
right context so you can monitor
multiple clusters in the single phase
and no matter if you have an
infrastructure view you want to look at
your clusters and your notes
specifically or you really want to take
a look at your workloads and deployments
or even at your kubernetes services so
all of this is integrated in the right
way cool and can I catch event and
actually take actions based on those
events maybe scale up scale down spin up
another cluster right so at the moment
with the beta we're surfacing events
based on incidents and incidents are
violations of alerting policies that you
may have and so but they're correlated
so we have an event timeline that you
can show if there was an incident then
you can correlated with the state of
your kubernetes environment to more
easily get to the root cause of any of
your issues and those policies can I
define my own policies right that's a
great thing with a stack driver and the
kubernetes monitoring solution that we
just announced is that it works great
standalone but it works even better when
you integrated with the rest of a stack
driver products so for instance you have
powerful and comprehensive alerting
system which stack driver monitoring but
you can then pursue hypothesis view
trying to root cause an issue and deep
dive into logs in stack driver logging
or even go beyond and try to see latency
analysis which that driver trays or
consumption of your resources would
stack grab a profiler and what about
bigquery can I tie all this back to
bigquery perhaps yes so in the stack
River logging has already exports that
you can make to bigquery Google Cloud
Storage and pops up and so usually many
of our customers take those logs
important to the query and do deeper
analysis and be interesting
do you have a demo maybe you could show
us a little bit about how this works I
do let me show you all right so this is
the stackdriver kubernetes monitoring
console and what you have here is an
integration of events and various
signals metrics logs and so forth in a
single place so the event timeline shows
incidents that may have happened and if
you're an operator you would look at
perhaps of the infrastructure so you
would go from your cluster to your node
and so forth if you're a developer you
may be more interested in your workloads
and deployments and so you can go from
your clusters to namespaces and pods and
containers or perhaps you go to your
services from cluster to namespaces
thoughts and containers once you're
interested in something you can inspect
the kubernetes object further so I'm
looking here at a particular container
and I'll see key metrics and all the
logs that are associated with that
container stackdriver kubernetes
monitoring works great standalone but it
works better with all the other stock
driver products so here I'm showing you
how you can use the metrics Explorer in
stock driver monitoring to further
inspect any of your kubernetes objects
so I'm looking at a pod and going deeper
to try to understand this metric by its
transmitted I can change the type of
graph that I have from a line to a stock
area or to a bar and then I can filter
down by metadata that may be
user-generated or from the kubernetes
environment so I'm filtering down here
to my service and then I can further
group down into whatever I want so
there's a very simple and intuitive
interactive way of inspecting your
kubernetes objects so that's a that's a
great demo on a really elegant interface
I can tell a lot of work went into the
UI UX in this in this interface what can
you tell us at this point about the
pricing
or stackdriver Oh so stackdriver
kubernetes monitoring follows the same
pricing that we just announced for a
stock driver and we have several
principles in defining this pricing
first one is to make it as simple as
possible so it's very easy for our
customers to estimate what they use and
forecast their spend and usage second
it's a pay-as-you-go model so depending
on on what metrics you ingest into stock
driver with locks you just interest a
crabber of the traces you have but then
you have a in you get automatic
discounts based on volume so all of this
is following that same simple model
that's great well thank you I hope you
enjoy cubed on Thank You Justin thank
you
you